Thank you so much for joining us.
Well,
I think we're gonna see a little bow.
The flip,
right?
I think we are.
Yeah.
And let's see our trailer when they have jobs.
My knees.
Yeah,
to surreal
that much.
I know.
I've seen them all my life.
This is my sister.
I don't think she's the right choice.
You don't have to trust me.
Yeah.
Don't miss your bride is frozen or on your hot bath.
Okay.
The parts of the House that are unsafe.
Oh,
Susan old is this one that comes in time and living thing.
As I go below this level
stops holding on to things.
Has anyone died in this house?
Specific deaths.
Violent decks.
Best interest.
Proceed with caution.
Keeping them alive when they shouldn't be.
You're here with me.
Gimme a sec.
She knows everything.
Do we have to do this?
Yes.
You have no idea what they do.
What do you want?
I have to leave.
You have nowhere else to go.
This is your home now.
We are.
We are also lucky.
You know,
today we'll be joined by the Castro.
Please also welcome Jessica,
Chaz,
Tom Hiddleston and Mya was.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Thank you all so much for being here.
Welcome to Google.
Uh,
so this movie was terrifying and I spent most of it just kind of like slowly
sinking into the jumping up every once in a while.
And so congratulations.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's this kind of horrific Jane Eyre meets flowers in the attic meets the
shining is what I felt watching it and that in terror.
Can you talk about some of the influences from it?
Well,
the,
and,
and the 18th century,
uh,
at the end of it and that reaction towards,
the age of reason,
there was a counter movement of Romanticism.
I,
one of the things that west created by back then was gothic romance and now
Gothic Romance,
they used to call it a blessing,
terror,
you know,
in the Victorian drawing or a rooms.
And,
uh,
it was,
a very titillating makes of violence,
uh,
sexuality.
And it was the,
the first time that in literature,
uh,
somebody created a romantic sensation about the past.
Nothing.
Romance is about the past and about the marriage of love and death.
So it's sort of the Prato.
He,
most of the have the wrong word versus the van.
I'm done in Victorian era.
It became an incredibly popular,
uh,
it affected Jane Austin.
It affected Charles Dickens,
the Brontez.
I mean,
you're going to feel the repercussions of it on,
uh,
anything from the secret garden to withering heights to great expectations and a
dollar days.
I mean,
I think that in many ways that is honor still alive,
very,
very different.
Now.
A lot of people,
when you say Gothic Romance,
I imagine fabrio and the cover of the paperback novel and an airport carrying I
girl a full of,
uh,
you know,
very ornamental dresses,
but ultimately that's,
that's part of the spirit.
But this is a genre that exists somewhere within fairy fairytale on horror and
romance.
You're not going to get pure horror and you're not going to get the,
you got mail sleepless in Seattle.
You're going to get a very strange mixture,
but beautiful.
I think
so.
What was it exactly that drew you to this?
You know,
I bite sized to fit your kind of filmmaking style in a freak for it too.
Yeah.
I mean,
I read the first movie I saw at age four was Wuthering heights.
And I don't know if that has anything to do,
but that,
that was the first movie,
and I've said it in interviews more than a decade and a half ago.
So I'm not an especially changing it for grins on big as my mother took me to
the movie and I was terrified and I was mesmerized.
It was the first time I saw him over on the big screen and I started reading,
you know,
the,
the typical things of Jane Eyre,
a withering heights and so forth.
And little by little I graduated,
um,
I have a big collection of Gothic Romance,
uh,
and Radcliffe,
which view rather than,
you know,
and Radcliffe,
uh,
was the preeminent,
a gothic romance writer.
Uh,
and finally there is a novel that I recommend for anyone curious called Uncle
Silas,
my Joseph.
It on the for new and it has a lot of the crimson spirit there.
But I wanted to make a movie that was beautiful and,
and sort of really creepy and dark at the same time.
Um,
one thing I loved about this movie is that you have two very powerful female
characters and yeah,
and Gothic romance doesn't always is,
sometimes it's those was with a girl and I meet the guy and there's something
going on.
But this is too,
Yup.
Very strong willed women.
Um,
so ladies,
could you talk about kind of your involvement in the film and what it was like
to step into these characters?
That was great.
I mean,
I,
um,
the characters kind of evolved as we went along and,
Gamma was super collaborative with us and um,
we had a lot of opportunities to discuss with him and then he really kind of
helped us tailor the characters to,
to ourselves in a way that,
or,
you know,
make choices that made it easier for us or,
um,
more truthful for us.
And that's really rare in a director and really always so appreciated.
So it was great.
I was really excited when I got the script,
uh,
because I'm not used to being in movies where actresses get to talk to each
other,
but I'm always looking for that.
Um,
I,
you know,
I did that help and that was probably the best experience of my life working
with those women.
And,
um,
so it was very excited about this.
And then also Guillermo had talked to me about,
um,
Lucille and Edith being kind of two types of love.
And there was something about Lucille that I just found so heartbreaking and
devastating and um,
and I just want her to explore it.
It was a,
it was a minefield of where you could go,
um,
psychologically and,
and how deep you could go into a character,
which for an actor that's what you want to do
was,
it was wonderful sort of seeing,
I feel like your character kind of represented this sort of innocence in
progression and wanting to move forward with love.
And then your character was so steeped in tradition and the past and like they
both were kind of fighting for your character,
Tom,
who was sort of stuck in the middle between these two important women in his
life.
And um,
uh,
you,
you guys kind of have a very interesting dynamic that progresses over the film.
Um,
what,
what to you was kind of like the point where you were like,
I,
I am solid in this character.
This is her decision to stake her claim,
um,
in Tom's character.
Um,
I would constantly,
it's funny,
I see the movie now too,
and this is,
I was talking someone in Toronto and they had just seen the film and I was like,
isn't Thomas Sharpe so selfish?
I was like,
because you know,
Lucille does,
she does for history in the family for every decision she makes is for her
brother.
And she even tries to protect Edith in the beginning of the movie by saying
she's too young and you know,
[inaudible]
I know what you mean though.
Sorry,
I'm just teasing that there is a sort of more interesting things is
not the charming,
I find it personally very.
Um,
what did I interrupt?
I'm sorry.
Oh yeah,
I suppose,
um,
uh,
yeah,
but I think,
I think in terms of what Jessica reads as Thomas,
his selfishness is actually a sort of struggle for freedom and free will and the
film dramatizes um,
a tension between the past and the future
is that Thomas Sharpe,
my character feels like he's,
he's,
um,
bound up by the past and literally haunted by the secrets of the past
and in love with the future learning and in love,
in love with the future in love with Eden.
Um,
eventually.
And that I think is a,
in so many ways,
God,
that's what Crimson peak dramatize is,
is,
um,
is that,
is it every,
each,
all three of us are,
our characters have a struggle to be free.
We're all fighting for something different.
And,
um,
and it's about how the secrets of the past can catch up with you if you,
if you don't confront them.
Um,
and somehow the three characters become self aware of the course of the,
of the story.
They,
they,
there is a kind of a battle for the truth.
And once the truth is out in the open air,
um,
some kind of resolution can be,
can be found.
But that was what Henry James,
the fine gothic romance you said is about,
and,
and it was so perfect is that it's about the,
the goals represent the past and is the struggle to move into the future,
you know,
and,
and it really is so well put,
so,
so eloquent and,
and uh,
you know,
the idea,
the idea for me in this movie is normally,
uh,
even when,
um,
uh,
they are,
they are mostly directed by men and they are mostly oriented towards,
uh,
some ideas of the past about the feminine.
That's why I love the Brontes,
you know,
the Broncos are so progressive for their time and they are so full of real,
sort of almost like a hall of mirrors of neurosis and real complexity.
And I wanted very much to make it about who saves the heroin.
Now I,
I'm not spying.
You guys saw it,
right?
So I'm not spoiling anything.
Anyone is here by mistake or ones the canopies we bought now,
Debbie,
I wanted her to save herself and I want to hurt in fact,
to be the one that saves the hero,
the guy that was going to save her.
Bruce and I,
and I tried to make two different different degrees,
the male figures quite useless in Hawaii.
And Thomas is almost a teenager emotionally in that he,
he's,
he's been loved and bullied and manipulated,
no pun intended,
into being completely dependent on almost is the sister and the mother and the
lover and it's everything.
Um,
he,
he kind of goes along and the father is dominant,
but he's incapable of having a really mature conversation with the daughter and,
and,
and either to become,
become a really strong moment.
I remember when we were shooting,
we would have weeks on weeks of either being scared and then I will need the
promise.
Mia tomorrow you won't be scared.
Tomorrow you'll be strong.
Our thank you.
But you have to map it.
Yeah.
I think one of my favorite lines was about,
uh,
wanting to be,
um,
Mary Shelley,
not Jane Austin and,
but she did anyway.
You know,
I'm,
the head of the funny thing is she gets her wish.
Yup.
Very mothering widow.
She predicted that one.
But no,
it was,
it's this wonderful sense that she,
she's in this relationship because she wants to be,
not because that's what society expects of her.
Um,
and I thought the scenes with your father were great because I was,
it was like,
oh yeah,
that's,
she doesn't care.
You know,
she's very modern in that sense and that she whatever,
you know,
um,
and that she wants to pursue her own career and,
and isn't going to be bothered by kind of what other people think.
Um,
what was it like working with the,
uh,
your father character in it because it seemed like such a short lift.
Important.
Jim was wonderful to work with it.
I think we actually shot all those scenes at the very end.
So we sort of started with all the stuff in the house and all the horror and it
progressively got more and more of a nightmare.
And then,
um,
we got to the end and we had the last three weeks were around like outside in
Toronto and it felt like a different film to,
um,
have some of those really lovely scenes with Jim.
And um,
and go actually back to the beginning after filming Nand.
Yeah.
Um,
let's talk about ghosts because they are awesome.
the,
so the ghosts in this movie as you were saying,
you know,
they do represent the past in the sense,
but there's also a very physical and metaphysical representation of them.
Yeah.
Um,
can you talk about where you decided to use them,
uh,
visually as opposed to this kind of,
you know,
the specter of them and,
and you know,
I don't know how these people lived in this house.
It's terrifying.
The thing is,
uh,
there are two things that are counterpoint in Queensland.
One of them is obviously in the normal movie that is gothic horror and all that
you want the,
the whole audience is rooting for the billings to be killed and when they get
killed,
you cheer.
And that's a huge release.
And I,
I wanted to go counter and if we did our job right,
for you to actually feel progressively more ambivalent about the villains and,
and go Jesus,
they do have a story.
They do have a bag.
And the same with the ghost.
The problem is,
the easiest way to scare someone is to give the goals and a Judaeo Christian or
a moral value.
Now you can say is the monic and it's something that people go,
Ooh,
I understand each construct his own,
but it's easy to make it scary because there are demonic or you say in this
house there lived a,
a woman that murdered her five children and stat her husband 20 times in the
eye.
Oh my God.
You know,
that's already,
there's a much more valuable,
the tricky line that I decided to do on Grimson is the ghost needed to be
revealed to be wanting to help either.
So I couldn't make them evil eye.
It still needed to make them creepy,
but I couldn't get,
they take full advantage of the other stuff.
And,
uh,
what we did is we said,
well,
they're all trying to warn her,
but conveniently the first ghost has no tongue.
No.
The second goes,
has a broken neck and it's finally the modern.
I've can talk,
you know.
And so we did it progressively and we wanted very much,
uh,
I decided to make them physical for the actors to have them on the set.
And you know,
I didn't want them to be acting against a tennis ball with an ex,
you know,
cause it helps much more to have it there.
You know,
it's,
it's just a decision,
I believe in makeup effects.
I believe in the craftsmanship of that.
And the whole movie,
the proposal of the movie was to,
for it to feel like a handmade film from the wardrobe to the ceds to the makeup.
I wanted it to be,
for lack of a better analogy and installation a world that you could fall into.
You know,
I think the best sort of manifestation of that is the house itself,
which was horrifying and beautiful at the same time where it felt very real and
it was,
I'm sure for you guys it was great actually being in a tactile scenario,
you know,
not being like,
please talk to this green wall of books.
Um,
but uh,
for me the house actually also sort of became a character in this,
this sort of symbolic form of your,
your siblings passed and what they're holding onto and it's just in the state of
decay.
Um,
what was it like shooting there?
What was,
I mean,
even if you look at this,
I haven't seen these costumes and a long time.
They're very painful to where I'm like,
oh my shoulders go up as soon as I see it.
I never tried them.
What was incredible about it is,
um,
the way Guillermo and the team designed is,
is that,
uh,
Thomas and Lucille,
our of the house and so,
so much so that the colors kind of blend into each other.
And there was even a hallway with the spikes around that look like teeth and
those are on my dress.
So there's all these subtle details and when I,
the first time I went to the house and they were building it,
I saw it in many stages if actually informed the character so much.
I mean she is really physically part of her past.
She,
you know,
it's painful for her to leave.
Have you seen it again?
And then I'm sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll continue on that.
But if you see it again,
the some architectural details are in the lace.
So I wanted Lucille to be the house very much to be linkedin if you say it again
when she gets angry,
the house breeds,
even when she's off camera on the beginning,
she's looking through the keyhole and the house breeds,
cause he's too near to her and she was watching.
And every time that she was going to get this flare,
the house reads and the,
and,
and it's because like in the house of usher,
another magical tale of incest,
the falling of the house and having our online polls.
The House represents the,
the k of the characters who sort of uh,
uh,
sort of,
an entity that contains them all.
You know,
sergeant drove in that way?
Well,
um,
honestly the,
the set on crimson peak was,
was the most beautiful sets I've ever seen.
Uh,
the most,
the most fully realized,
um,
architects really sound I've set I've ever worked on.
It was,
uh,
it was really extraordinary.
It was like,
cause often,
often as actors we,
if it's a,
if it's a smaller film that sat in the contemporary world,
you use real locations.
If he,
you know,
if you're shooting in a restaurant,
you could find the restaurant and shoot there,
but it all feels natural.
Or if you're in a,
in a very,
um,
if you're in another,
in another realm and other university,
there necessarily is so much post production,
um,
computer graphics.
Uh,
but this was,
was physically there.
And it was like stepping through a magic portal into another world.
It was truly a,
um,
an immersive experience.
And I think that the time we all spent on the set was about six weeks,
six weeks of shooting at the beginning.
And,
and using different parts of the house,
you could walk up the stairs,
you know,
um,
everything you see,
it was real.
And for Ross,
I think not having to supply the detail with our imaginations and just having to
live and breathe and behave and respond to each other in the house was,
was,
is that really rare privilege as an actor?
Well,
it's very claustrophobic.
Six weeks and that house was pretty tough,
I can imagine.
Yeah,
yeah,
Yup.
Um,
I mean I think the house is such an important symbol and especially for your two
characters who are in a very interesting kind of power dynamic.
Um,
you know,
they are siblings,
but it's a time,
it's a very patriarchal time and yet the seal wears the,
not pants,
but pants.
She wears the petticoats I guess in the relationship.
Um,
but to me it was about very much kind of breaking out of tradition and breaking
away with family,
which is doubly hard to do.
And then some extra complications that come along with it,
their relationship.
Um,
what was,
what was kind of that development like for those characters because it's,
you know,
your character kind of came into his own with a certain set of consequences,
uh,
out of that.
And
I'm trying not to,
we can't spoil anything.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean,
one of the things,
it was a wonderful weekend,
uh,
before we started,
about two weeks before we started,
I was doing a play in London and Jessica and Guillermo came to see me and to see
me in it,
which is lovely.
And then the next day we spent the whole day together talking about this
relationship.
Um,
and,
uh,
we had been friends before too,
so it was a very comfortable place to start.
And it was a,
you know,
really was about jumping straight into the complex intimacy between them.
You know,
they have,
they have been codependent from a very,
very young age,
um,
uh,
grown up without parents.
Um,
you know,
from,
from pre teenage years essentially.
And,
um,
and so there is,
there is a degree of,
of intimacy,
which is,
uh,
which is actually a very precious and very delicate.
Um,
and the difficulty comes when when of course their individual desires and
characteristics start to separate.
And,
uh,
so I think actually kind of calibrating that and plotting that out it was,
um,
was,
was fascinating.
I've,
I personally find it fascinating too,
to really kind of find the points of difference.
Um,
and the points of similarity,
um,
which I felt were very,
can be very true.
People,
the people that are different from each other.
And there's something very interesting in that.
This is 1901.
Um,
and,
uh,
we'd,
the period setting is not an a,
is an age where,
and this is what Edith is pushing against rightly,
um,
is a woman's power is expressed through the men closest to her.
Um,
and I think it's amazing that that's what Guillermo is decided to put at the
center of his film.
That it's about,
um,
it,
it really is about female strength.
Um,
uh,
but,
but Lucille,
and maybe you could speak to this,
but Lucille is having,
is forced into a situation where her status is expressed through Thomas,
but Thomas has his own ideas and his own ambitions,
um,
and supper and his own heart,
quite simply.
Um,
it is the very individual,
um,
heartbeat he has,
which separates them in the end.
Uh,
what'd you think?
Well,
uh,
it was speaking what you were,
you know,
along the lines where you're talking about with the patriotic article society.
These are two people that have made every decision together.
Uh,
you know,
and then it's really interesting when you,
when the movie begins,
it's you actually,
without knowing it,
when you're watching the film,
you witness the cracks in that because for the first time,
I think in their lives,
he's starts to make decisions without her.
Hmm.
Uh,
so you see that from the very beginning of the film and then when we get back to
the house,
that really is where Lucille starts to f to gain her power again.
Um,
so much so that even with the,
the costumes and the sets,
you know,
um,
Lucille,
the longer she's in the house,
the bigger she gets.
Even with Clark her.
Yeah,
they happened to me too.
So with Mia with it,
she would get smaller or the,
the,
the furniture around her would get,
we made the furniture and in several sizes,
but also the Lucille has this condescending point of view about what it is to be
a female in the world.
I mean,
she's,
she's that character with many scars and I think that I make a blind done.
I find it very funny,
but it's very cool when you see the portrait of the mother,
you know,
I have no doubt of their upbringing.
And then they talk about their father breaking her mother's leg.
I mean,
one of family.
Yeah.
But she makes a point to either that if you're pretty,
you are delicate and I think that that's a wrong information.
Um,
and I think that that's why we use the Motif of the maths on the butterflies.
Or Lucille thinks she's a math as he's all powerful and you know,
dark than either of his,
because by virtue of being of a son of this position or American or young,
I'm pretty,
she must be a little butterfly that she is going to be able to pin to her.
Wallen and the whole point for me was to show not butterflies can be brutal,
you know?
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
even visually you did such a lovely job of having,
you know,
you stood out in the house and these wonderful yellow colors,
which are,
or you had us and I saw them assemble one of those Kudos to you for wearing that
because that thing looked complicated.
Um,
but it's,
it,
it was very interesting.
Did you feel kind of being dressed that way and being in this kind of,
did,
did that help you kind of stepping into that part of it or they're definitely
super uncomfortable,
you know,
horrible.
And I've swore off to my first period film,
I'd never do another one again.
And that hasn't happened.
But,
um,
they're great.
They do give you like a certain kind of,
there's only really one option two in how to carry yourself and be,
so there was a certain amount you draw from them and they're really beautiful
and Kate who designed them is just a genius.
So I,
I,
yeah,
I have like a love hate relationship with them for sure.
You were very strong butterfly in them,
so thank you.
I had various different wings,
different sizes,
large way.
Um,
I've got to bring up a point just because I felt like this was a parent's
cautionary tale because there was a line in the beginning.
It was,
it was your father character.
And he just goes like,
I don't like him and I don't know why.
And I've just broken,
I scribbled down and was like,
listen to Dad,
listened to dad and then your,
you know,
your mother's kind of warning you against stuff.
And uh,
it was,
it was very interesting kind of having these specters of,
of parental history,
uh,
speak out against this male character and just go,
no,
like,
nope.
Bad idea,
bad idea.
Um,
I wasn't sure if that was kind of guiding away from the historical role of a
gothic romance male.
What is interesting for me is that there is,
uh,
Thomas arrives to that meeting,
I think would all every intention to woo or the American investors,
her father in particular,
and there's a very subtle moment where the feather notices that she's looking at
him from the door.
Um,
he doesn't like that is this very patriarchal thing from the 19th and 20th
century where daughters basically,
if they didn't marry the,
they took care of the father,
you know,
and there is that sort of jealousy and he doesn't like him because of that.
But also the beauty for Thomas is that I think he likes you this,
but little by little he falls in love with her on the beginning.
He actually,
I think he invites her to the world's to split,
to offend the father or to go against that,
that he feels,
but I think that it's those little things that interests me.
I think the father is a character.
I understand,
but I think that it's a character that I sympathize with in many ways,
but he,
he,
he should,
he should have just straight out.
Like in every melodrama,
there are things that some people don't say is your,
he's your father,
you're her brother,
whatever.
They keep it for the whole movie.
And the father have told her straight away,
and this is why I don't like him.
I found out this.
But he didn't trust her to be that strong.
And that's what it's done.
It's interesting,
I think,
uh,
barons in the movie at the root of,
of his graces.
And the other thing I wanted to do is most of these movies end up with the,
the,
the dark and brooding gentlemen actually being innocent.
And then he can be condoned.
And Meredith and this,
I wanted them to love each other in spite of what he had done.
And for horror to start with the marriage not end because normally these movies
and everybody's happy throwing rise and I say,
no,
no.
That's when things start,
actually,
yeah.
This is life after that implies that marriage
to a point,
I'm going to embarrass him or not,
but I,
uh,
the,
the Naugles talk about my tennis shoes now.
Very beautiful shoes.
Mail mailers.
Yeah.
I'm not going to talk about Guillermo's foot.
He,
he,
when I came onto the film,
he shed a number of gothic romance novels as me,
chief among,
which was,
as he's already mentioned,
the mysteries of your Dorfer by an Radcliffe's,
um,
which is I think almost the first time a writer had,
had,
had written a story about the supernatural explained in terms of past trauma.
Um,
but there was in a way,
if she,
she was one of the primary inventors of the genre of Gothic Romance,
a young,
innocent heroin at all dark stranger,
uh,
to whom she is drawn by some sort of,
um,
sexuality and charisma only to be surprised and terrified by certain secrets.
Um,
and that seems to be like what gothic romance is all about.
So the rebellion against parents is,
it is a way of taking possession of your own sexuality,
I think.
Say,
I ain't gonna,
I ain't gonna Chase this.
But then the twin aspect of gothic romance is the prospect of death is that,
is that sometimes at your sexuality can put you in a dangerous situation and af
after which you will never be the same.
And I think that's what gamma so beautifully,
um,
kind of brings together in this film as it is a while doffing his hat to
traditional gothic romance.
He inverts it and can bounce people's expectations.
I think it's,
I personally think it's like,
so it's also important to show the heroin fucking I'm surviving.
I think that the gothic romance and fairy tales have are two types,
an archaic or repressive,
a lot of the fairy tales heart.
Be careful on the way you're a parent and,
and,
and horror functions in many ways the same way.
And it chastity from the main character or sexuality gets punished.
And we,
when we were working,
we said we have to make it a point,
but she is not Buhr [inaudible] she is and she has to be in charge of the sex
scene.
She has to be willing and it has to be,
you know,
I gave him the is not,
is not a negative.
I mean I think,
I think the movies and when you go against so many things against the grain,
there's a different feeling to the movies sometimes less commercially able to
and trap you.
But I think is far more satisfying in the long run.
I mean it felt much more sort of realistic.
It's like we can't you
the human race has continued on and there's one way it did.
If it was real,
pharmacist would sell condoms and are gone.
But no,
it was
really an interesting kind of embrace of sis.
Like being like,
look,
they'd,
and,
and the,
I like that your character initiates it,
you know,
she's very embracing of it.
She'd knows that this is something logical that comes as the next step in their
relationship.
And when,
you know,
it's just a Tavis is kind of reticent.
She's like,
nope,
we're going to,
I'm going to find a way to make this happen.
Been like,
I'm going to make you some tea.
No
Pass.
Um,
there's a kind of
the thing that does go hand in hand with the amount of passionate and stuff that
goes into this film and that's the violence that comes out of it.
Um,
and it's just,
it felt very kind of the other side of that coin where it's like,
these are our very passionate,
caring characters who maybe don't know how to communicate.
I'm sure what she was raised by this horrible band.
Yeah.
And the way they communicated was through that.
That was the thing.
You don't understand that she has scars in her face.
There was a scene where she used to have her back exposed on,
she has huge scars in her bag.
She took gainings for her brother.
She says that,
and you know,
she,
she's sort of,
you know,
uh,
I think all,
all of the mistakes that exist in the world initiate in childhood.
If we,
if we took care of children for the first 10,
12 years of their life,
the world would be perfect.
But it's because that is,
that is what destroys them as kids and they carry it the rest of their life.
Yeah.
We're going to open it up to audience questions about it.
If anyone wants the lineup.
Uh,
one question,
I'm really afraid to ask this from PMO,
but,
uh,
no,
I was going to have a free to ask.
What's something that scares,
you know,
I
people,
I mean I'm afraid of politicians.
I'm afraid of 12 super structures.
I mean,
I think,
I think that uh,
we live in a world where,
uh,
I think that another thing that scares me,
and this is why I made the movies because I thoroughly believe in love and I
think that has become almost something to be afraid of.
I mean,
we are almost in the equivalent of modern times to Victorian Times,
Victorian Times.
It was afraid of sexuality and they use this tales to talk about sexuality in a
veiled way.
And I think that we,
we are in a world where I feel we,
we,
we become very reticent to talk about emotion and love.
That scares me a lot.
And I think,
uh,
because we,
we don't want to be vulnerable and we want to,
the,
the automatic pool is to be distant and aloof.
And you're instantly are smarter if you're a skeptic.
And I think if you're a believer,
you're instantly sounds tubular.
And this things to scare me quite a bit.
And,
and you can see it like when people think about why those twilight,
it's so successful,
strangely enough for whatever gothic elements Twila has,
you realize that now we're using it to articulate a love.
That's what they couldn't,
they couldn't talk about sex in Victorian era.
And now the only way that a fantasy about a perfect love can be articulate is
gothic.
You know,
this is strange.
The guy has to be a vegetarian by buyer
and never,
it's,
it speaks of the Moore's over time.
It feels very,
it's kind of cyclical where we're kind of reverting back in.
Um,
all right,
cool.
Hi,
when we were watching the trailer earlier,
I,
two thoughts go through my mind.
The first was I wonder how many times you have seen that trailer as you,
as you were standing in the back.
Uh,
but the second question was,
when I saw the trailer,
I thought there's gonna be a lot more about ghosts.
And I was curious how you decided,
what's the process of making that trailer?
How do you say what you include,
what you cut?
Well,
actually I got up to speak this way because they put the little thing here,
but uh,
it's very strange.
But I told me that film maker,
it was involved somewhat in the marketing,
but not fully,
you know,
I,
you have to watch,
uh,
with faith on horror when they market your movie.
Um,
it's a mixture of,
depending on how good the marketing department is,
they captured the essence of the movie somehow.
Now,
gothic romance is particularly gauging because he's not a whore.
If you go expecting a full blown horror movie,
you're not going to get it.
And if you're go expecting full blown Romans are not going to get it.
So I,
I actually think Clemson is hard to communicate the full spectrum of the movie.
I think it's more a drama.
We'd go centered,
which is what Eden says.
I bought her story.
Uh,
but how will you communicate them in a,
in a sort of purely commercial way.
So I don't know.
I love the trailers that they've been doing.
I think that represent one side of the movie.
And inevitably there will be a sign of a movie that people have not seen.
Well,
Dell discover in the theater,
but that's why we do these things.
That's why if you like it,
help us send word out,
they'll tell your friends,
you youngsters,
all those things.
Yeah,
thanks.
And I've seen it in a shuttle load times
actual number counts.
Hey,
um,
this is a question for Tom.
I'm a huge fan of everyone,
but especially Tom.
Okay.
And my question was,
it's actually really funny because I like you a lot as an actor,
but I found your character the most despicable of the characters in the movie.
And so I have this inner confidence.
I feel like Lucio was so obviously messed up towards the end.
You could tell
your character,
you know,
you could sense a bit of good in him,
but that almost made his actions worse.
So I was wondering if you could talk a little bit about that and then maybe how
you drew that out in your portrayal.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
well,
yeah.
Um,
I think I found,
um,
the reason I wanted to,
the reason I wanted to play Thomas was when I first read it,
I could see a character
embroiled in,
um,
some very dark action and material,
so guilty and so shamed and,
and really struggling to free himself,
uh,
struggling to somehow write the shit back onto an even keel.
Someone who was actually impelled by who understood,
who is beginning to understand his own shame.
There's so much shame and the character and uh,
and someone who was actually innately gifted.
I th I think the engineering is engineering gift,
has mechanical,
um,
the sort of inspiration and capacity is a very genuine talent.
And someone,
if he,
if he had been,
uh,
a healthier kind of mine would have maybe gone on to be a great industrialists,
a great engineer.
Um,
and I think,
I truly think that Edith is a,
a light which shines on him and it takes them completely by surprise and,
and she shows him how to be good.
And,
and then for the rest of the story,
he's struggling to weigh his responsibility for the past and his desire for
freedom,
a sense of responsibility to Lucio and his love for her,
which is unhealthy and lots of ways,
but he still loves her kit and it comes from damage.
And one of the defining quotes that we was a headline for us was damaged.
People are dangerous because they know how to survive.
And,
and,
and in spite of what you found despicable,
which is completely within your rights to feel
you're frying in the inside.
I'm sorry.
No,
it's okay.
Cause actually the reason I to play it was it was
someone moving from a place of shame to try to be a better man.
And I do think that there is a redemption that he achieved the kind of
redemption without spoiling anything,
it's clearly not an easy one.
Um,
and there is a catharsis that he finally is able to concede a responsibility and
take and be accountable for what he's done.
But he makes a couple of very,
very good choices towards the end.
And so I,
in a way,
I,
I will defend him to the death.
But then so with these fine ladies at my size,
so that part of the job of an activist is to be,
is to,
is to fill the shoes of somebody else from a place of compassion.
So I can only,
I can only feel his,
um,
I can only feel and understand his pain.
And you know,
if,
if I were to have to defend him,
I would say,
well,
he is who he is because of what happened to him.
And Lester Guillermo said those choices were taken away from him when he was
very young.
Um,
so it actually has this beautiful arc from,
from shame to freedom.
Thank you director.
And the cast for gift giving me very terrifying and a violin movie.
Yesterday I was a kind of shaking file four or five times and the my seat,
when I saw some of the hands creeping and like the,
the thing on the head ghost was pretty like scary.
Um,
so my question was that initially when the,
in the,
even in the character of Amir's character where she tries to get her story about
ghosts and get through and she's,
uh,
the reaction she gets is like,
hey,
why didn't you,
nobody wants to the release.
He goes,
they do the really like it.
Why don't you do a love stories?
And she's a no,
it's just a store even close to knit.
How story,
right?
So in real life,
like I don't really get to see that many ghost stories.
It's,
if you look at movies,
most of them are like the characters.
Um,
they,
they tried to say it's more like love stories and feel good movies.
This one came up so I jumped into the chance to get in.
Last one,
I think I saw as evil dead in 80s or 90s.
So,
um,
do you as a watching list?
Yeah,
some came,
but then the girls for a more like shadows and they didn't,
it was mostly laughing along the way.
But this one was different.
I didn't laugh at all.
What you're saying actually,
that that used to happen.
Like the Brontez,
all the Bronte sisters,
all of them had the Polish under a pseudonym,
a male.
So the name,
they kept their initials,
CV,
you know,
ab and so forth.
What they,
they they had to,
to publish under a male pseudonym.
I'm purposely in many ways even changed our narrative a little.
So it was less evident that they were female.
And to this day,
I mean,
I call her either for either of Warthen who was,
in my opinion,
I was good with ghostly Dale's house,
Henry James.
But people tend to call this,
qualify her as a Pale imitator of haylage Henry James.
It is it,
those were things,
mason and some facts.
And what I like is that if you watch carefully at the end and the credits she
wrote the novel about Crimson Begun,
her first experience is based on our goals that appear to my mother.
And when she was a kid,
my grandmother sat on her bed the night she died and dodge her in the shoulder
and she heard the springs and the bed creaking and he used to dominate this
things irresponsibly when I was [inaudible].
Yeah.
Is that the,
how do you like judge between whether to make this kind of a movie,
which are very rare then gender,
the compared to versus like,
Hey,
let's make a love story has like actors.
How do you to jump in to do it or see it as a director?
How do you like try to like bay between the movies?
I only do weird shit.
I visited the second time I've worked with Guillermo.
I did,
um,
Mama with him that he produced.
And I like doing his weird movies so much.
The character of Lucille.
I,
you know,
sometimes actresses,
actors,
everyone gets typecast and I'd never played a character like that and I just
loved her.
So that's,
for me it was a great opportunity to play the role.
Yeah.
I,
I'm always drawn to,
um,
complex material.
I think,
uh,
I I enjoy,
um,
I enjoy characters who have a very,
uh,
kind of have
deep souls in a way.
They're complex people.
Cause I think most people are actually a very complex.
And so if I read a piece of writing like this was,
you can eat the sensitivity and the delicacy with which the human characters are
written was incredibly inspiring.
Uh,
I tend to think the types of characters,
some of the types of characters you see in movies,
you know,
they,
um,
I'm sure we could all think of things that we just go out and that was a bit
Finley drawn and these characters were so multidimensional there.
Seems there seems so rich,
so real
in a way.
Um,
big fan of this guy.
So that's why I did it.
Make you need to have you iman.
Thanks dude.
Um,
I,
I just like same one to 12 with Guillermo.
I think he's brilliant.
I loved his
films and,
um,
and I really liked the character.
No,
I wanted to see what would happen with it and where it would go and,
um,
yeah,
and it was,
it was a great experience.
So,
yeah.
Well,
thank you all so much for joining us today.
Oh,
it was such a pleasure to have you and everyone go enjoy crimson peak.
[inaudible].